two of twitch's biggest streamers ninja
and pokemon are currently feuding with
one side threatening legal action this
story has hate raids threats in the dms
and even deleted vod clips
it got ugly here's all the details
[Music]
this all started when judeon a youtuber
who creates comedy and prank videos was
streaming on twitch and sent his
followers to type l plus ratio in
pokeman's chat while she was streaming
this was done while giuliana was playing
an old video pokemon repeatedly saying
the n-word on stream during the stream
jiren told anyone with a penis that
pokemane would not sleep with them and
that she was getting [ __ ] down by
somebody else with everything happening
in her chat pokey ended her stream early
saying that while she could handle it
she didn't want her community to be
subject to what was happening through
whispers which is twitch's version of
dms despite this being his first
partnered stream jideon was handed a
14-day ban which was then upgraded to a
permanent ban on his same hate raid
stream according to pokemane judeon sent
his community over to ninja stream and
asked him for help so he wouldn't get
banned for what he did ninja responded
saying that there was literally nothing
he could do but eventually said that he
would text his twitch representative
about this for help ninja said on stream
that he's going to do whatever he could
but julian was quote
adding in the future if you're going to
ratio [ __ ] to which he clarified he
meant [ __ ] generally
stick to twitter
don't set don't
no nothing negative no l's don't spam
your chat to raid someone spam else
don't rate if you're gonna ratio [ __ ]
that was my i meant [ __ ] in general
isn't like you guys like your mom
that [ __ ] did you you know what i'm
trying to say in another stream of hers
pokey claims that ninja's wife and
manager jessica blevins dm'd pokey
saying that ninja did not call her a
[ __ ] and that he told gideon that what
he did was not okay jessica said that
ninja never said that he would try to
get judy on unbanned and doesn't support
that and also sends screenshots of
direct messages between the two men
pokey replies saying that's not how she
saw things go down and she would have
appreciated a different course of action
from ninja both publicly and privately
jessica replies to this and this is
something she will stick to saying that
ninja never said that he would try to
get gideon a lesser ban
and he never texted any representative
at twitch poki then presents a clip
where ninja discusses what was the
two-week ban and says he is still down
to play with him once the band is up
pokey claims the vod where this happened
was deleted after she messaged jessica
about it but she downloaded it before
this could happen because she saw the
other vod of ninja stream deleted but
she found the original vod with the two
men's original interactions clipped it
and sent it to jessica trying to prove
her side of the story jessica replies
with ninja's version of events once
again saying that he never tried to get
judy on a lesser ban and never texted
his twitch representative and that's
pretty much the important stuff this was
all via pokey retellings by the way and
in her retelling she said that the
harassment was more than just l plus
ratio
but this wasn't the end of the dm's from
the blevins during the stream pokey
holds up her phone to show what looks
like to be recent dms for ninja where he
swears on his late grandfather's life
that he did not send that text and that
she is quote making a big mistake later
pokey posted to twitter what looks like
to be dm's from jessica saying that they
see this as defamation of character and
are considering getting their legal team
involved pokey conceded that she cannot
prove whether or not ninja sent the text
ninja also tweeted replying to someone
about the situation that all will be
explained but it seems that tweet has
also been deleted gideon has apologized
and has asked his fans to stop pokeman
shared a final breakdown of her version
of events including that gideon tweeted
negative hateful things about her before
the raid and that during it her subs
were being messaged and harassed by
gideon's followers and that's it for now
but if there is more in the coming days
i will be sure to let you know
[Music]
[Music]
bye